Speaker 1: OK. This is now just it's.
It's sad that it has gotten to this point.
Donald Trump has suggested that at times past, it
would have been appropriate to put some Hillary
Clinton operatives to death, to death, to kill
them. There is a supposed spying operation.
There's a court filing that happened last
week, which I'll mention briefly and it
almost like doesn't really matter what the
facts are. But I'll mention that last week,
it was alleged by Special Counsel John Durham that
Clinton campaign lawyer Michael Sussman paid tech
companies and researchers to mine internet data to
establish an inference and narrative tying Trump
to Russia. This was reported by Fox News, and
the right became absolutely titillated by it.
Trump put out a statement. Saying the latest
pleading from special counsel Robert Durham
provides indisputable evidence that my campaign
and presidency were spied on by operatives
paid by the Hillary Clinton campaign in an
effort to develop a completely fabricated
connection to Russia. By the way, even
if true, that's not what the allegations
expose, but OK. Trump goes on to say this is a
scandal far greater in scope and magnitude than
Watergate. That's not true. And those who were
involved in and knew about this spying operation
should be subject to criminal prosecution
in a stronger period of time in our country.
This crime would have been punishable by death.
In addition, reparations should be paid to those
in our country who have been damaged by this. I
would say, at what point do we have to say this
isn't funny anymore? But the thing is, we said
that the day after Trump was elected in 2016,
it's now even more not funny. It's hard to even
know what words to apply to this. Are there no
consequences for threatening violence as long
as you're in a position of power and have money?
Something is very, very wrong here. Something
is wrong that we have so many people that hear
this and they say Trump's right go on the right
wing enclaves, go on the right wing subreddits,
check out Rumble where I'm now, you know, bank
paying attention. Now that we're putting our
content up there and people hear Trump say
this and they say he's right. These people
should be put to death. They've not been even
charged with any crime, never mind convicted.
It's not even clear they did anything illegal, but
they're there. It's not just that Trump is saying
they should be put to death. There is a contingent
of the country that says they should be killed,
and something is also very wrong that there are
never any repercussions for any of this stuff.
If you're in a position of power, of course,
absolutely incredible. And the fear is, I mean,
listen, you guys know what the fear is, right? No
repercussions for any of these people. We already
saw how effectively Trump can incite a riot. We
already heard from Trump at his recent rallies.
We're going to have even bigger protests if they
charge me with anything. If these investigations
lead, we will have the biggest protests of which
is again, Trump alluding to his supporters doing
violence. His supporters seem ready to do
more violence. And we should be scared.
We should be scared, and I try never to
be hyperbolic here, but at this point.
I am very worried about what the next eight and
a half months leading up to the midterms will
look like and then depending on what happens in
the midterms, depending if Republicans take over
what is going to happen in the lead up
to the 2024 election, very, very scary.